je
manifestation monstre en corse et les
syndicats de la fonction publique en
grève depuis quatre semaines durcissent
le temps grève générale du secteur
public demain municipal record
d'affrontements triangulaire et cadres
angulaire au second tour à quelques
exceptions près le front national et les
verts se maintiennent de l'ingratitude
des peuples de la permanence du péril
communiste le créneau d'une heure alpino
chez un entretien exclusif dans ce
journal des bactéries dans l'oreille
c'est bon pour le saut un casque
révolutionnaire mis au point par une
firme japonaise
mais monsieur bonsoir il y a aussi les
bonnes nouvelles des événements qui
confirme que l'on peut croire au progrès
dans le domaine médical ce sont le
diagnostic et la technologie prénatal
qui bénéficient ces derniers temps des
avancées les plus spectaculaires
ainsi on vient d'apprendre qu'à lyon une
greffe de cellules a été réussi sur un
foetus de sept mois atteints d'un
déficit immunitaire mortels une greffe
effectuée donc dans le ventre de la mère
c'est une première mondiale réalisée il
ya quelques mois par le professeur
touraine à l'hôpital edouard herriot de
lyon est tenue secrète jusqu'ici à la
demande de la famille le bébé n'est
normalement depuis est encore dans une
bulle pour quelques mois
cette technique représente donc un
nouvel espoir pour les enfants bur
jusqu'ici on avait réussi les greffes
mais après la naissance
c'est grâce à cette technique que nous
allons rencontrer avec alain labouze et
pierre laurent constants un garçon de 12
ans en pleine forme
il s'appelle certains furent condamnés à
mourir parce qu'incapable de se défendre
contre les infections
certes duo qui a aujourd'hui 12 ans l'a
échappé belle
les 18 premiers mois de sa vie il les a
passées dans une bulle
il n'y avait pas de donneur de moelle
compatibles et puis un jour à lyon on a
tenté l'impossible la greffe de tissus
provenant de foetus mort et ça a marché
comme que j'ai pas imiter parcours
c'était solide pas comme un but parce
que c'était moins sympathique et on fait
des meneurs moment je peux retourner
dans l'allée dans l'infini mais ne veut
plus ça d'après ces mêmes parents qui
suivent la laisse voir je vais pas
entièrement des sports en fait qu'ils
restent en lice taille réforme ses
dépens c'est ici dans ce laboratoire que
l'on prépare les cellules de foie et de
thymus extraites des foetus mort à ce
jour 50 et enfants ont pu être greffés
avec ses cellules 66% sont
définitivement guéri il y a à peu près
une centaine d'enfants à traiter chaque
année soit près naissance soit avant la
naissance par une greffe de cellules
foetales nous manquons de ces cellules
ce qui est important c'est que nous
soyons prévenus chaque fois qu'un foetus
décède dans une ville de france pour que
nous puissions faire le prélèvement est
organisée la transplantation
on n'a pas le droit d'utiliser des
foetus mort disent certains et pourtant
c'est la seule façon aujourd'hui de
sauver des enfants comme sérgio grève
générale du secteur public demain mais
aussi en corse-du-sud entreprises et
commerces fermés c'est en tout cas ce
que demandent les ce représentants
socioprofessionnels du département qui
met en cause bien sûr la grève des
fonctionnaires
une grève qui dure depuis plus de 4
semaines maintenant et qui a donné lieu
aujourd'hui
ajaccio et à bastia aux manifestations
les plus importantes dans l'île depuis
25 ans gérard leclerc deux caddies en
tête de la manifestation
l'un le corse aux trois quarts vide
l'autre le continental plein pour
symboliser les écarts de coût de la vie
dans les rues d'ajaccio et de bastia dix
mille fonctionnaires un sur deux en
poste sur l'île postiers pompiers
enseignants agents des divers services
publics réclame depuis quatre semaines
une prime d'insularité 2000 francs pour
la cgt force ouvrière ou une
augmentation de 15 % des salaires pour
la cfdt et le syndicat des travailleurs
corses et l'impatience grands
dans l'attentisme et on a l'impression
qu'il nous prend pas au sérieux
donc on se demande ce que je connais si
ajaccio le cortège s'est dispersé dans
le calme bastia une centaine de
manifestants ont lancé quelques pierres
et des charges et une benne à ordures
devant la préfecture
oui les prix dans l'alimentation
notamment cent plus cher encore ce que
sur les continents mais bizarrement le
sujet presque tabou comme l'a constaté
sur place françoise joly 12h30 place de
la préfecture à bastia l'heure est au
pique nique pour les manifestants
jean-pierre entame sa quatrième semaine
de grève agents des impôts il a
travaillé quatre ans à paris en 1985 il
est rentré au pays
j'avais un enfant de 8 mois
quand je suis rentrée donc et pour tous
les produits spéciaux pour bébés dont
j'avais besoin était vraiment d'un coup
vraiment très supérieur à ce que je
quittais pratiquée à paris et ça m'a
surpris je n'aime parler avec ma femme
et on s'est dit on est revenu en corse
est d'accord je suis chez moi dans mon
pays mais et des difficultés qu'on
n'avait pas à peser quand on était à
paris et le coût du caddie dans les
grandes surfaces
le coût de tous deux produit dont on a
besoin de tous les jours c'est quelque
chose qui va falloir mesurer d'enquêté
il va falloir faire attention et il est
vrai que lorsque jean-pierre rempli son
caddie cela lui coûte cher par exemple
15 % de plus qu'à poitiers pour les
produits alimentaires
la corse est en effet en tête des
départements les plus coûteux mais pas
facile ici de savoir pourquoi les prix
sont si élevés personne ne veut parler
ou alors on accuse à demi mot pour
certains c'est la faute aux
transporteurs qui assure la liaison
entre la corse et le continent
chaque année l'état leur verse 750
millions de subventions objectif
abaisser le coût du transport des
marchandises les différentes compagnies
de transport a su répercuter cette
baisse certains professionnels en doute
les subventions nous les boulangers nous
ne percevons pas ne sommes pas au
courant
ouvrons ces suppressions qui
subventionnait et puis malgré des taux
de tva plus avantageux comme par exemple
sur les carburants
l'essence est ici une des plus chères de
france les associations de consommateurs
soupçonné stations-service 200 tentes
pour pratiquer des prises
une hypothèse démentie par les
intéressés aujourd'hui on fait le pari
en bas en basset vous verrez que toutes
les stations ne sont pas identiques
hommes ont pris pour ça va peut-être
venir
depuis hier l'insee envoyé sur l'île des
observateurs une nouvelle étude des prix
est en cours la direction de la
concurrence et des fraudes de bastia et
elle en déplacement à paris pour
rencontrer l'administration centrale et
remous dans les milieux hospitaliers
grève aujourd'hui des chefs de clinique
assistant et des maîtres de conférences
des chu grève encore des infirmières
anesthésistes mais les internes ont
accepté les propositions du ministère de
la santé la nuit dernière
quarante deux duels 48 triangulaire dix
cadres angulaire ce sont les étranges
figure du second tour des municipales
dans les villes de plus de 30 mille
habitants un record dans la complexité
du évidemment au maintien des deux
formations qui vont arbitrer ce second
tour
beaucoup de ballotage donc arbitrées par
le front national et les écologistes
les écologistes sur de leur succès selon
leur chef de file d'antoine waechter qui
table sur une entrée en masse dans les
conseils municipaux les grandes
formations bien sûr continue de flatter
les électeurs verts en lire jacques
chirac dans le figaro de ce matin et
michel rocard dans le nouvel observateur
michel rocard qui affirmé hier soir à
béziers où il était allé soutenir le
candidat socialiste
personne n'a le monopole du combat
écologique mais à béziers c'est le front
national qui fait grincer les rouages le
rpr en effet décidé d'exclure le maire
sortant georges fontès pour cause
d'alliance interdite véronique salive
habiter la droite fait des couacs cinq
listes au premier tour et georges fontès
le maire rpr sortant déstabiliser qui
prend avec lui pour le deuxième tour de
membres du front national
l'ancien ministre de jacques chirac n'a
pas hésité ni son exclusion du rpr ni
son abandon possible par une partie de
l'électorat modéré ne l'ont fait reculer
que tout choix très clair tant pis si je
peut indisposer qui que ce soit
n'importe quel niveau des états-majors
ce que je veux c'est garder la ville de
béziers dans laquelle je suis né et à
laquelle je suis attaché par dessus tout
georges fontès revendique aujourd'hui un
apolitisme congénitale mais il atterrit
nerfs lui lève bien haut le drapeau du
front national je considère que monsieur
fontès a peut-être une attitude que lui
dicte son état major
mais en tant qu'homme je ne suis pas
aussi sûr de son antipathie vis-à-vis du
front national cette bavure fait la
sphère de la gauche alain bas rhin le
chef de file socialiste se frotte les
mains
on a peur avec les communistes devraient
lui permettre de capitaliser toutes les
voix de la gauche l'alliance rpr front
national ramènera aussi quelques
abstentionnistes du premier tour j'étais
donc c'est un plus pour nous dans une
ville où jean moulin est né il ya
beaucoup de gens des républicains des
démocrates qui sont choqués par sa est
ce que ça vous étonne non pas du tout
d'ailleurs je l'avais déjà indiqué avant
les élections il a été successivement
parti socialiste à l'udf au rpr il a
étêté délices du rpr et maintenant il a
fait cette évolution avec cet accord
avec le front national
je dirais que c'est une dérive et c'est
un isolement supplémentaires résultats
de la mêlée dimanche
si georges fontès ne transforme pas
l'essai la droite biterroise restera sur
la touche pour longtemps
la gauche elle récupère à une ville
qu'elle avait perdue en 83 autres
mesures de rétorsion venu d'en haut
le président du cds pierre méhaignerie
retire son investiture aux candidats cds
de mantes-la-jolie aussi pour cause
d'alliance avec le front national
à sarcelles c'est entre socialistes et
communistes que rien ne va plus le
bureau exécutif du ps a une nouvelle
fois demandé aujourd'hui aux dirigeants
communistes de retirer leur liste face à
son secrétaire national
dominique strauss kahn qui a reçu en
revanche le soutien des écologistes
explications jean-michel mercure arfel
bataille pour une cité dortoir la
compétition pc ps du premier tour
avaient placé le socialiste dominique
strauss kahn président de la commission
des finances à l'assemblée
loin devant la candidate communiste
marie claude bodeau pc + ps plus perçu
le total des voix de gauche dépasse et
52%
bref une élection quasi-certaine pour
dominique strauss kahn dimanche si
toutefois le pc avait respecté l'accord
de désistement pc ps je déplore
que nous n'ayons pas pu pour ce second
tour des élections municipales nous
mettre d'accord avec le parti socialiste
nous prenons aucune responsabilité dans
cette affaire c'est bien le parti
socialiste qui prend la responsabilité
on ne nous donnant pas ce que veulent
les sarcellois pour notre liste dimanche
prochain non je crois qu'on peut
comprendre le désarroi qui a saisi
l'appareil du parti communiste qui est
battu pour la première fois mais lorsque
les socialistes étaient derrière ils
sont toujours des cistes et pour les
communistes on peut encore essayer
d'arranger ça et que de toute façon il
faut mobiliser l'ensemble des forces de
gauche pour qu'elle se reportent sur la
liste socialiste est arrivée en tête de
façon à ce que la gauche majoritaire à
sarcelles gagne la main sarcelles
c'était 18 ans d'union de la gauche
jusqu'en 83 aujourd'hui le maire sortant
rpr raymond la montagne voit subitement
renaître ses chances d'être reconduit il
était virtuellement battu au soir du
premier tour le second tour se présente
bien à gauche qui le dit georges
marchais qui est sorti de son silence
tout à l'heure sur rtl il a cependant
admis un certain nombre de bavures mais
pour lui il ne s'agit pas de sarcelles
ou de noisy-le-grand mais de bègles
longwy et ou sarlat où les socialistes
ont refusé de s'effacer devant les
communistes grassement aussi entre l'udf
et le rpr à propos des problèmes
d'horloge ou de sombres complots à aix
en provence vous savez que pour deux
minutes de retard la nuit dernière la
liste commune laborieusement mise au
point entre les deux formations sans
front national n'a pu être déposée la
commission d'investiture de l'unef
demande solennellement aujourd'hui hors
pair de retirer sa liste udf n'est pas
en panne a déclaré par ailleurs son
porte parole alain lamassoure qui
répondra plus précisément demain matin à
7h45 aux questions de gérard morin et
puis demain soir à 22 heures toujours
sur antenne 2 bien sûr dans le cadre
diddy sion spécial pas vraiment un face
à face mais plutôt un côte à côte
entre robert vigouroux jean claude
gaudin et aussi des interviews des deux
autres candidats qui s'affronteront pour
le second tour à marseille dimanche
prochain
édition spéciale donc exceptionnel avec
auxerre et lyon demain à 22h30
spécial consacré à marseille complot
machination injures la haine même plus
ou moins feutrée entre différentes
corporations
le procès du commissaire jobic qui se
poursuit à nanterre en fait tous les
jours l'état l'âge et la confrontation
se poursuit entre le policier et le juge
hayat par témoins interposés rémy roche
suis pour nous prendre un des moments
les plus tendus les plus dramatiques
sans doute l'un des moments clés de ce
procès patricia boschetto une prostituée
toxicomane témoigne à la barre elle est
en larmes elle vacille quand elle
raconte comment en juin 87
le juge hayat lui a proposé de tendre un
piège à sjow bic le scénario remettre
aux commissaires des bijoux ou de la
drogue
pourquoi les gendarmes puissent opérer
un flagrant délit un scénario que refuse
d'exécuter boschetto qui va tout raconté
aux policiers de nanterre confession
enregistrée dit-on à son insu dans leurs
bureaux mais qui ne donnent pas lieu à
un procès verbal comme il l'avait fait
l'autre jour pour contrer les
accusations du commissaire jobic et
jean-michel hayat dément formellement
avec force détails en reprenant toute la
sphère depuis le début ils démontent ce
qui pour lui est une odieuse machination
dont en fait
patricia boschetto ne serait qu'un
pantin une machination qu'il décrit
d'une telle importance qu'elle confère
soudain à cette affaire jobic une
dimension extrêmement grave car cette
machination impliquerait une partie de
la plus haute hiérarchie policière
oui et cette information de dernière
minute toujours à propos donc du procès
jobic la défense du commissaire a rendu
public le rapport du commissaire
divisionnaire en ce qui concerne le juge
ayad donc parler bien sûr rémy roche
nouvelles interpellations hier soir à
cannes dans le cadre de l' enquête sur
les attentats contre les foyers
sonacotra de la côte d'azur un ancien
para a été placé en garde à vue
neuf interpellations à ce jour et
policiers ont mis la main sur un
véritable réseau comme le révèle hervé
brusini et patrice voulait lancer des
roquettes sur la gare saint charles de
marseille
mitraillé les voyageurs il y pensait dès
1984 dans leurs petits groupes d'extrême
droite
à l'époque ils étaient 4 4 avoir
entreposé les fusils mitrailleurs des
grenades le plastique dans un box d'une
résidence cannoise leur unique objectif
terroriser les immigrés les arabes
l'un d'eux sont mt même vanté nicolas
gouges marman au buffet de la gare de
cannes
il affirmait à qui voulait l'entendre si
jamais je fais des attentats je signerai
samassa da ils croiront à une action
sioniste discrètement à l'inspecteur des
renseignements généraux avait noté
l'anecdote
jusqu'au jour où les premières bombes
ont explosé était d'abord visé le siège
local du parti communiste la cgt en 88
que foyer sonacotra de cannes la bocca
quatre blessés le 19 décembre cette fois
il ya un mort un travailleurs roumains
qui vivaient dans ce foyer de cagnes sur
mer
sur place des tracts portent la
signature de massada des renseignements
généraux explore leurs archives et
retrouve la piste de gouges les poseurs
de bombes filature judiciaire gilbert
beauchamp 68 ans est finalement
interpellé chez lui on découvre le
matériel utilisé pour la fabrication des
textes de revendication et le petit
nécessaire du parfait artificiers en
tout une dizaine de personnes sont à
présent impliqués dans cette affaire
la plupart sont membres du parti
nationaliste français et européens
gouges lui appartenait aussi à
l'association la france avec sa police
gérard printemps et le responsable local
il était l'employeur de gauche
il était correct aussi que ce qui était
noire avec des arabes avec des français
ou des européens
maintenant lorsque sa journée est
terminée si on a eu une discussion avec
lui on senti qu il préférait le blanc à
la couleur
les enquêteurs affirment que leur
travail est loin d'être terminé
d'autres interpellations aient ce soir
même ont eu lieu un inventaire à la
prévert à donner le frisson aux
responsables de la prison de montpellier
imaginez ce qu'on a trouvé dans la
cellule d'un détenu qui devait
comparaître aujourd'hui en assises pas
de [ __ ] laveur mais un fusil à canon
scié huile hymne à métaux un uniforme de
gardien et leur cahier de roulement le
prisonnier n'a pas réussi à s'évader
attendre mesures spectaculaires aux
états unis pour tenter d'enrayer la
criminalité et trafic de drogue
le patron de la lutte anti drogue qui
fait partie du gouvernement a annoncé la
suspension de l'importation dans le pays
d'armes semi-automatiques
une mesure qui fera plus l'opinion
publique que les criminels dans
l'arsenal est amplement pourvus et ce
sont les policiers qui en font
régulièrement les frais paul nahon
new york 1er mars dernier l'officier de
police est vrai thatcher est tué dans
l'exercice de sa fonction
il tentait d'arrêter un trafiquant de
drogue qui a tiré avec une arme
semi-automatique new york à brooklyn
deux jours plus tard l'officier de
police james o'connor est retrouvé au
volant de sa voiture le corps criblé de
balles
il tentait lui aussi d'arrêter des
trafiquants de drogue qui ont tiré avec
des armes semi-automatiques
ap les américains en ont plus qu'assez
de voir les criminels beaucoup mieux
armés que les policiers chargés de
maintenir l'ordre
la décision de george bush concerne
seulement les armes importées aux états
unis des armes comme celle ci un ak-47
de fabrication chinoise ou des armes des
pays de l'est en 1986 4000 semi
automatiques ont franchi les frontières
en 1988 44000 toutefois 75% des autres
semi automatiques sont fabriqués aux
états unis et ceux là sont toujours en
vente libre dans les magasins du pays
c'est le début un petit début mai un
début important significatif de
changement de la part d'un président
républicain et donc qui s'est toujours
identifié au lobby pro armement
conservateur à l'ordre moral si l'on
peut dire est qu'ils commencent à
changer et je pense que ce changement
justement les images que vous avez
montré qu'ils relatent ce qui se passe
dans la police
ce changement vient des profondeurs de
la police et deux personne concernée par
l'ordre policiers et trafiquants de
drogue se livrent en effet à une guerre
sans merci
une guerre qui est gagné par les
trafiquants grâce un armement très
nettement supérieurs accalmie
aujourd'hui à beyrouth après les
bombardements d'hyères beyrouth ville
morte cependant les habitants sont
restés chez eux une petite plage au
soleil le long d'un golfe clair et une
plage qui vaut son pesant de dollars à
tabac cette enclave sur le golfe d'aqaba
occupé depuis 22 ans par israël
le drapeau égyptien a été hissé
aujourd'hui en vertu de l'accord conclu
le mois dernier
l'egypte a payé 38 millions de dollars
en compensation
son espoir développer le tourisme local
des manifestations vous venez de voir
ont eu lieu en israël
l'entretien a été enregistré il y a deux
jours
une occasion rare qui méritait que l'on
se plie à ses oreilles scène
d'interviewer le général pinochet
président toujours dictateur ou
dictateurs gagner un peu par la
démocratie au chili vous le savez les
spéculations vont bon train
bernard benyamin nous le disent et hier
d'autant plus que le gouvernement vient
de proposer aux partis politiques
une réforme de la constitution et ce en
fait une manoeuvre pour permettre au
général pinochet de rester au pouvoir
c'est la première question que je lui ai
posé je ne peux vous répondre ni par oui
ni par non j'ai la charge d'une fonction
et jusqu'à la dernière minute je la
remplirai s'ils me disent de continuer
je continue sinon j'arrête c'est le
problème du peuple et pas lumière et
c'est à dire que d'ici un an
vous risquez d'abandonner toute vie
publique en accord avec la constitution
je retournerai dans mon régiment comme
chef des armées parce que je suis le
garant de cette nouvelle constitution
j'ai juré sur l oms publique en 1981 un
monsieur pinochet puisque l'on vous voit
en civil depuis le départ forcé du giro
stroessner du paraguay est ce que vous
ne vous sentez pas un peu seul non non
vous vous trompez complètement la chute
du président strottner c'est la chute
d'un militaires causée par d'autres
militaires
ce qui s'est passé au paraguay avec ce
président stroessner n'est absolument
pas comparable à la situation du chili
et à son président ce sont deux cas de
figure complètement différent
la répartition des classes sociales est
différente la géographie du chili et
celle du paraguay ne sont pas
comparables
même la manière de vivre et distincte
pour la politique c'est la même chose
monsieur pinault chez vous vous savez
bien sûr que le reste du monde continue
à vous considérer comme un dictateur et
comme l'un des tous derniers dictateurs
sur le continent sud américain
non mais moi je n'ai jamais été un
dictateur dictateur avec un pouvoir
législatif un pouvoir judiciaire
tout ce qu'a décidé ce pouvoir
judiciaire a été appliquée
religieusement
qu'est ce qu'un dictateur parce que j'ai
du caractère face aux événements
dictateur vous vous trompez complètement
en fait c'est que le monde souffre d'une
maladie
cette maladie c'est le marxisme des 10es
par les gauchistes monsieur pinault chez
l'évolution d'union soviétique avec
mikhaïl gorbatchev est ce que vous
pensez
selon votre analyse que le ce que vous
avez toujours dénoncé comme le danger
soviétique est moindre aujourd'hui
appeler ça des homonymes
vous voyez je pense que le communisme
n'a pas changé ce que fait gorbatchev
c'est en jolie v toute l'idéologie
marxiste léniniste et il la présente à
l'opinion publique comme un autre modèle
et dans le fond c'est pareil il n'y a
pas vraiment de changement
la doctrine soviétique se maintient à
100%
est ce qu'après quinze ans de pouvoir
vous avez l'impression que votre
personnalité a changé ma personnalité
n'a pas vraiment changé et ce depuis mon
enfance
une personnalité dur mais entièrement
préoccupé par ma fonction
tentons de faire tout mon possible avec
mes facultés
je travaille aux heures par jour vous
croyez peut-être que je m'occupe
seulement trois ou quatre heures
d'entretiens donc enregistré avant-hier
dans ce même studio ce qui explique le
changement de fès de ma part en tout cas
une interview exclusive obtenu grâce à
bernard benyamin et pascal stelletta
santiago puisse encore que la politique
ce sont les raisins qui préoccupe
aujourd'hui le gouvernement chilien
les raisins de la colère puisque les
états unis le canada et le japon ont
bloqué leurs importations de fruits
chilien éric perrin
y at il du cyanure dans le raisin
chilien les états unis le canada et le
japon ont décidé d'interdire
l'importation et la vente de ses fruits
après la découverte de traces de cyanure
une enquête a été ouverte en europe où
tous les tests pratiqués jusqu'à présent
se sont révélés négatifs
le gouvernement militaire chilien accuse
les communistes d'être les instigateurs
d'un complot visant à saboter les
exportations agricoles
de l'agriculture en union soviétique
devant le comité central réunis en
plénum michael gorbatchev a plaidé pour
sa réforme agricole
mais il semble ralentir le mouvement et
renoncer à des transformations radicales
dans les mois à venir
néanmoins il a reconnu que la
collectivisation agraire des années 30
avait été une erreur
allant jusqu'à dénoncer les méthodes
force est pratiquée sous staline
émission du numéro deux du gouvernement
grec
agamemnon croûte soyaux gas il était
depuis quelques mois la cible de
l'opposition qu'ils impliquent dans la
sphère cosco tu as du nom du banquier et
magnats de presse georges coste potasse
accusé d'avoir détourné de l'argent est
versé des pots-de-vin à des membres du
gouvernements d'andréas papandréou coups
de soleil orgas est une personnalité du
pasok le parti socialiste grec
ce n'est pas contagieux ce n'est pas
mauvais pour la santé et c'est bon pour
la musique
découvrons une nouvelle qualité sonore
grâce aux bactéries
et oui des bactéries dans les eaux règne
ou plutôt dans les membranes d'un casque
haute fidélité révolutionnaire mise au
point bien sûr au japon sous le casque
patrick espère
excusez-moi christine mais vous voyez
j'ai un peu tendance à me laisser aller
quand j'écoute de la bonne musique avec
un casque comme celui là dans votre
musique qui nous donne envie de
remercier mozart bien sûr mais aussi de
remercier la cette aube acteurs à ces
petits lacets tobback terre assez dit
bien ce sont ces millions de bactéries
que les japonais ont eu l'idée de faire
travailler à leur place pour produire
les membranes de ce casque
révolutionnaire en 48 heures ces
bactéries vivant le bien sûr vont
déposer une couche de cellulose il ya un
peu gélatineuse cette couche de
cellulose est récupéré par les
techniciens qui vont assécher la forme
et pour donner la membrane
vue au microscope électronique voici la
structure de cette bio cellulose qui
permet d'obtenir des centres et fidèle
très naturel rien à voir avec les
sonorités métalliques des casques
classiques mais les techniciennes sony à
tokyo ne se sont pas arrêtés là
la direction leur ayant donné carte
blanche ils ont utilisé leur ordinateur
pour concevoir des formes nouvelles
n'ayant rien de commun avec la
miniaturisation le son ne se forment
plus au milieu du crâne mais semble
venir naturellement que chaque oreille
comme pendant les concerts véritable
objet d'art
le casque est taillée dans du zelkova un
arbre au moins bicentenaire est très
rare au japon 500 casques seulement
seront fabriqués rien à voir avec les
grandes séries de l'industrie japonaise
ah pardon mais j'ai oublié le prix 39
ans et oui pourquoi 500 casques
seulement parce que les arbres précieux
sont protégées au japon championnats du
monde de patinage à bercy à paris
jusqu'à dimanche prochain
on attend demain les duchesnay le couple
de patineurs français dont les libertés
de steen
à défaut de convaincre toujours les vues
plaisent beaucoup pour public terrible
en pot
ils sont la coqueluche du public les
enfants terribles du patinage artistique
a croire qu isabelle et paul duchesnay
n'ont qu'une passion l'originalité mais
voilà si le spectacle est toujours au
rendez vous de leur prestation il leur
manque l'agrément des juges et pour les
faire jaser encore le maximum cette
année isabelle et paul duchesnay ont
basé leurs programmes sur un charleston
bien pour le public
- bon pour les notes au fond on
préférerait peut-être laisser les gens
voir si j'arrive à à reconnaître qu'on
essaie de démontrer à la fois complice
et entraîneurs martin short ni qui les
aident à accomplir leur petite
révolution travaillent sans relâche à la
patinoire d'oberstdorf en allemagne pour
conquérir une nouvelle fois demain le
public de bercy
ce matin au cours de l'épreuve de danse
imposée ils n'ont eu aucun problème à
exprimer leur talent demain il s'agira
du programme de création
c'est là que les du chéné dérange en
préférant le spectacle à la rigueur du
règlement à vous de juger
demain les pronostics de cars adresse
pour le quarté qui aura lieu demain
aussi à evry le 2 le 5 le 1 2 10 le 17
le 14 le 8 et le 12 voilà c'est sophie
davant qui va vous parler du temps de
demain dans un instant et puis philippe
lefait vous donnera les dernières
informations de la journée vers 23h20
demain bien sûr rendez vous avec toute
l'équipe de télématin partir de 6h45
très bonne soirée sur antenne 2 à demain
20 heures